if you haven't noticed lately we're
living in the future
technology that was only imaginable in
science fiction is now so mundane
that we practically take it for granted
but there's still one thing that's
conspicuously absent from our futuristic
present
where are the flying cars i was promised
flying cars
i don't see any flying cars why why
why the one thing that both utopian and
dystopian visions of our future
have seemed to agree on is that by now
we'd be flying around our cities
but for the vast majority of us who
don't happen to own private helicopters
we still mostly move around at or below
ground level
often stuck in congestion but over the
last decade a growing cadre of
bootstrapping startups and industry
stalwarts have been raising
and spending oodles of money on a new
mode of transportation known as urban
air mobility could these autonomous
human ferrying super drones
finally be the flying cars that we've
been waiting for
i think there are two things that are
driving
the investment and the attention to the
sector
the fact that people are moving to
cities and cities are getting more
congested
and urban dwellers don't want to own
cars so anything that can move an urban
dweller from a to b is interesting to
investors we saw it with micro mobility
solutions
we saw it with share mobility solutions
the next natural step is
shared aviation solutions
the concept of urban air mobility isn't
totally new
for decades helicopters have been a
means for those with means
to hover and glide over traffic in major
urban centers like new york
san francisco and sao paulo
past attempts to turn helicopters into a
form of mass transit however
have been grounded mostly by the
inevitable problems of helicopter
technology
noise inefficiency and danger
thanks to these issues many cities have
either limited or banned helicopter
transit outright
except for limited use such as in
emergencies
but imagine a future which instead of
driving your own car or hopping on a
city bus or subway
or taxi you could cut your transit time
significantly by booking a flight
on a sleek safe and relatively quiet
electric-powered drone
or e-vtol short for electric vertical
takeoff and landing
if we look at just 0.1 percent
of the americans that are driving in
their cars from work to home
and we assume that's going to be our
addressable market
we're talking about a hundred thousand
passengers a year more or less than need
to be moved
if we assume that these aircraft can
carry about four to five people
and they're doing four to five trips a
day
we would need roughly 5 000 of these
aircraft
so that gives you a sense of the massive
opportunity we have here
given this potential market the field is
unsurprisingly
very crowded there are over 180
companies developing some type of a veto
a lot of them are drone developers so
it's all about scale if i can build a
small version i should be able to scale
it to a larger version
one of these drone turned mega companies
is ihang
a chinese firm founded in 2014 that has
already earned a spot on nasdaq
from the very beginning we designed big
drones
to carry passengers right and second you
can see
that for normal drones the technology is
one-on-one
that means we need one person to control
each drone
but for us we design the system to
control many multiple aevs
simultaneously by using one single
platform
ehong recently secured approval from the
korean government
to perform test flights over seoul
showing off the company's prototype
during a recent three-hour tour
although ehong is designing its remote
control prototype to fit applications
ranging from medical evacuations to
sightseeing it's this so-called last
10-mile problem
that seems to be the most ripe for
disruption for example if you take
take a train to to arrive in beijing
right
the train takes about one or two hours
right
and after the train if you take a taxi
you know it takes another one hour or
even two hours
to go to the destination which doesn't
make any sense
but if you can transfer our av
right it takes maybe 15 minutes to
arrive
at at the your destination that's very
cool
meanwhile on the other side of the globe
a german company called volocopter has
spent the last decade or so
designing a fleet of prototypes that
have recently been flying in
demonstrations
over cities both at home and abroad
we are extremely pragmatic we set out to
build
a vehicle that can meet the high safety
standards that can be certified
based on existing technologies that are
available today
what came out is the volocopter we
explicitly designed it as a multicopter
process concept so we have you know
18 independent rotors that give us
a very high degree of redundancy so any
two any three rotors can fail and we can
still safely complete our mission
which gives us a huge safety advantage
over any other concept
and particularly on the urban mission
where it's about you know safely
transporting
people from a to b in an urban context
as quiet as possible we believe the
multicopter concept is
the winning design for that particular
mission there may be other missions that
require different design concepts
volocopter's ambitious plans have
attracted interest from a number of
large companies
hailing from other sectors of the
transportation world
such as chinese auto giant gili
germany's daimler
and most recently japan airlines all of
whom have participated
in funding rounds for volocopter that
have raised well over 100 million euros
so far
of all the companies currently working
on ev tolls volcopter seems to be the
furthest along and committing to a
launch date
already taking reservations for flights
beginning as soon as 2023
at an introductory price of around 300
euros
but the main hurdle that could disrupt
that timeline isn't merely a technical
one
this is a very safety critical you know
transportation mode
and you need to make sure that you have
all relevant stakeholders involved so we
are
really relying on the buying of the
regulators and you know gaining their
trust
so we always talk to them and be like
okay do we have an alignment of vision
do we have the civil aviation authority
on board do we have the airspace
manager on board you need to make sure
that you have alignment because any one
of those stakeholders can block you
from ultimately you know achieving your
goal part of the added challenge in
gaining regulatory approval for civilian
carrying ev tolls
is that the standards issued by
regulatory agencies are evolving in
tandem with the technology itself
they have to be ear worthy these
aircraft
they're going to be running on batteries
and batteries need to be
also approved as safe enough to be in an
aircraft
for this particular application
[Music]
volcopter ehong and other well-heeled
eevee tallers
such as lilium and joby are each taking
a slightly different approach to
engineering an
all-electric passenger drone some of the
designs are more of a hybrid between an
ev
tall and a small plane capable of both
navigating a dense urban environment
and flying long distances at up to
almost 200 miles per hour
and while some of the engineering
solutions for challenges like battery
capacity
are pretty innovative such as
volocopter's hot swapping charging
stations
any evital's viability ultimately comes
down to proving its safety in a variety
of conditions and scenarios
so assuming that evtol technology
eventually passes those regulatory
hurdles
that still leaves a very important
question about this untested market
who exactly are these for
if we look at elon musk's master plan
that first iteration in 2006 he was very
clear he said he was going to build an
expensive car
to help paying for a less expensive car
to help pay
for a mass market car so i think we're
going to see something quite similar in
this
specific segment where companies will be
offering the service
to high-end consumers but in the end
that will subsidize the technology so
that everybody can access it in the long
term
mass adoption of urban air mobility
though might pose its own potential
issues
once the product trickles down and more
people start using it we fear
it might actually cannibalize users from
public transit in cities
which will have negative consequences in
our view
mainly because it will just shift
congestion from the road up into the sky
before we get to that point though these
companies face yet another technical
challenge
integrating urban air mobility into the
existing transportation landscape
on this front uber is taking advantage
of their own learned experience building
a revolutionary ride sharing platform
to bring their technology into a third
dimension and they're not even waiting
for ev tolls to get started
back in the quaint pre-pandemic days of
late 2019
i gave their uber copter service a world
all right we're on road to jfk
yeah i can take this to work every day
we're really thinking of this
as kind of a version 0.1 of our vision
of this future uber air product the key
thing what we think
is the the important learning that we
are developing right now
is this foundational feature kind of
this core core experience
of multi modalities so true
multimodality so we're
with a single button press for the
product we dispatched the first mile car
the helicopter and the last mile car
bi-directionally from downtown to jfk
and and we're using our technology to do
that all behind the scenes
admittedly it's extremely satisfying to
fly above new york city's snarling rush
hour traffic and plop down on the
landing pad at jfk airport
within 10 minutes where a car is waiting
to shuttle you directly to your terminal
but even uber understands that once the
novelty wears off
it needs to make economic sense in order
for customers to adopt it
the economics of these vehicles will
allow us to push and bring it to be a
much more accessible product
that a broad a broad base of users can
use on a daily basis we actually think
the long-term vision we can actually get
to the point where flying um
in in these types of aerial networks can
be competitive
with driving your car with owning a car
in terms of like the marginal cost of
ownership
it's not going to happen right away it's
not even going to happen in the medium
term but we think in the long run that
we can actually make
flying in this type of a fashion kind of
a
economically rational thing for most
people to do every day
despite the sleek renderings of swanky
rooftop teleports and city skylines
buzzing with ev tolls
the commercial case for urban air
mobility is still up in the air
putting pressure on the company's vine
for viability
given the complexities of the solution
the complexities of the regulation
we do not expect to see a very diverse
ecosystem in the long term we rather
expect to see
a few a handful of developers of
manufacturers
working with a handful of service
providers
and that consolidation seems to already
be underway
in late 2020 uber handed off its
ambitious elevate project
to joby the current ev tall valuation
king
with nearly 1 billion dollars to its
name so far
boeing and airbus seem to be stepping
back from their experiments as well
some of the smaller startups have
vanished entirely leaving behind expired
domain names and
silent crunch base profiles so as the
field narrows the technology matures
and the regulations are ironed out you
may someday find that this perennial
sci-fi fantasy
could become another mundane option for
getting around
the way that we envision this to play
out is ultimately the customer whether
it's a citizen in the city or a visitor
to the city
you know has their mobile phone has a
mobility need and he just gets a choice
of different transportation modes
each you know comes with a price point
with a
comfort point to it and and a
predictability point to it and then he
chooses whatever is the best format for
him
and obviously we're working very hard to
make your choice as often as possible
you